Wes when you first start writing a stage
play or a screenplay even for a short or
feature is there a structure that you
follow do you start outlining what's
your process let's suppose you have an
idea you have a story you want to tell
what are some of the things that you
first do in the beginning for me I let
it sit for a while you know I let it sit
for a while and I tend to what I've
learned for me over the years from my
own personal kind of instrument is that
when I first started I would get excited
about an idea and I would tell everyone
about it I would call my my brother I
would tell my friend I would tell I
would call you and tell you I would call
him and tell you no and then because
because you're excited about it and I
think that's a good energy to have when
you have a story to tell but what I do
now is that I don't tell anyone about it
and I think that's important for me
because I think you wanna it's almost
like a boxer you want to get into the
ring with as much energy as possible so
that when the bell rings you're coming
up you know swinging and and what I
discovered over the years is that when
you spend all your energy telling people
about it and then you get in front of
the computer you have no energy you've
done telling people about it right so
for me I keep it all bagged up I get
excited about it and I talk to myself
about it and I think about it a whole
lot and I get it to the point where it's
about for me it's about 70% done I never
want to get to the point where hundred
percent done because you want to allow
for some room for inspiration and
changes so I gave it to the for me I get
it to the point where it's about 70
percent figured out and then there's all
this kind of energy kind of boiling and
then I wake up really early in the
morning have my coffee and I just sort
of like spend all that energy getting it
out onto the page and then it's on the
page and then you have a little bit of
you know kind of security and then you
can maybe tell people about one scene or
whatever but you know I I think it's
good to keep
the energy wrapped up that's interesting
because I think there's I think there's
a lot of people here that don't when
they first come here and I'm just
wondering was there a turning point was
there like something that happened where
you said I think trial and error I think
I think like for everybody and I even
know what works for me may not work for
other people I'm a morning person like
the right during the day I know what my
habits are when I get into a writing
block you know when I get into a writing
block I I do I always always go hiking
by myself interest I almost always go
and watch movies by myself and you know
and again other people have different
things you know and for me I've gotten
to know my kind of instrument over the
years I got to know how I like to work
and how I like to solve problems you
know so for me not telling people about
the story works how do you know you're
in a block I know that sounds like a
really strange question because it
sounds like it'd be so obvious but maybe
you're not in a block maybe you're just
like tired how do you know that you're
not tired or something else isn't going
on but it's an actual block of the story
that's a really good question I do think
that sometimes you get tired I think for
me if it's this sounds really kind of
weird but and I'm sure a lot of the
writers who might be watching this might
understand because there's such an
esoteric kind of a writer Lee you know
but I'm really good at that
you know but but but I see I think I
think if the writer is too much in the
driver's seat that's a bad thing I think
at some point this story has a life of
its own and I think in some ways a
writer has this sort of surrender to you
know the to the story to the characters
you know I think
I mean you know some some of this work I
mean I mean you know I wrote this really
successful play in you know idea was
produced in 2012 and you know it was
really well received and I'm proud of
and incredibly proud of it that script
came out of me like in two weeks you
know wrong and the idea came to me like
three in the morning you know in a flash
and so there's something kind of
spiritual and and and metaphysical about
that that I try not to answer and figure
out you know yeah you know so I think
when you start to get too formulaic when
you start to try to like shoehorn
too many things together when you free
yourself like bullshitting and you know
it's weird I mean it's it's a fine line
of being authentic and formulaic be
being inspired and being disciplined
those are really kind of weird kind of
intersections so in other words it
sounds like you don't really all want to
overthink it too much and have like a
name for the process you just know it's
instinctual yeah I try to it's a balance
it's a balance we keep on going back to
the word balance it's a balance you know
because I I tend to be very petty at
times but you know you don't want to go
overboard which I don't think is a bad
thing because it keeps you on track you
know because if you go too far out you
might be too much of a dreamer and all
these ideas are there and you're telling
everybody but nothing's happening right
whereas how you talked about earlier
when you knew you just had like no 90
pages wasn't gonna works
it's got to be 75 because it's gonna
caught you know I mean that's yeah that
sounds like it's working I think I think
all I want the project was again you
know unique because it's a collaborative
project with another person Melissa
who's you know very personally tied to
the story in terms of her you know
heartstrings you know and and and so
you know I didn't have the ability to
make all the decisions you know in a
vacuum you know for better or worse you
know we had to really have conversations
about you know character and plot all
along the way which is you know
different from you know previous
projects in the sense that I kind of
wrote it on my own
and I I kind of wrote it on my own and I
kind of had my idea of what I wanted to
accomplish so yeah
you